les foyers d'immigrés de la région
parisienne sont-ils surchargé c'est la
question posée aujourd'hui en forme
d'affirmations par la sicile un
organisme chargé de superviser les
constructions de ces foyers rapports
analysés par bernard sega si l'on s'en
tient aux chiffres de l'étude les 264
foyer de travailleurs immigrés d'île de
france sont sur occupés soixante-trois
mille lits effectif
soixante dix mille personnes s'y
entassent affirmé que les conditions
d'hygiène et sécurité sont précaires est
une évidence parmi les résidents
clandestins une majorité d'entre eux
seraient en règle à l'égard des permis
de séjour et de travail
une majorité certes mais pas tous
d'après les responsables de ces foyers
depuis plusieurs années le refus par les
préfectures d'appliquer des procédures
d'expulsion
à la suite de décisions de justice a
abouti en fait à transformer ces foyers
en ghetto en refuge pour délinquants ou
la prostitution le trafic de drogue et
d'armes ne sont pas exceptionnelles par
ailleurs ces chambres qui sont prévues
pour les personnes seules abritent
souvent des familles entières
ce qui ajoute au désordre parmi les
occupants un peu plus de la moitié est
d'origine maghrébine sensiblement moins
depuis le retour de nombreux algériens
dans leur pays d'origine
en revanche les locataires originaires
d'afrique noire a triplé de son gaz à
1982 la fissiles qui construit ces
foyers reconnaît que le parc existant
est loin de répondre aux besoins plus de
onze mille demandes insatisfaites en
le vrai problème qui se pose pour les
foyers de travailleurs et celui de
l'insertion des immigrés dans la société
française les foyers des temps
normalement conçus que pour une durée
limitée